Is "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever" a
worthy follow-up to the original film
or does it fall short of excellence?
Here's what the critics are saying.
It's premiere week for "Black Panther: Wakanda
Forever," and members of the press have attended
special screenings of the film. Before they're
allowed to give their official reviews, writers,
critics, and influencers take to social media
to share their initial reactions to the project.
Now that critics can expand on those initial
reactions, we're getting down into the nitty
gritty of "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever."
There are still some rave reviews for the flick,
but some more negative responses
are starting to come through.
As of Tuesday, November 8, the Rotten
Tomatoes score for "Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever" has been hovering in the
mid-90s. As these reviews continue to pile in,
this number will rise and fall but it looks
like critics are absolutely loving the sequel,
but it's not without its flaws. As to be expected,
many reviews mention the emotional roller coaster
fans will ride while watching "Wakanda Forever."
Deadline's Pete Hammond said of the sequel,
"There can be no doubt Coogler has
meticulously thought all of this out,
while still delivering the rip roaring
action sequences and uncredited surprise
appearances we expect from any Marvel
movie, but especially its crown jewel."
Coogler was praised in many reviews, which should
come as quite a relief for the director who had
a tremendous amount of pressure on his shoulders
when making this film. According to Richard Roeper
of the Chicago Sun-Times, "'Black Panther: Wakanda
Forever," quote, "succeeds as a new adventure,
and as a tribute to a wonderful actor who
was taken from this world decades too soon."
Additionally, Jamie Broadnax of Black Girl
Nerds is calling "Wakanda Forever" the best
film of Phase 4, making it the perfect film to
close out this segment of "The Multiverse Saga."
But while many critics are praising
the movie, a nice chunk of them have
some quibbles with the movie's pacing and
focus. Richard Lawson of Vanity Fair writes,
"Some will no doubt miss the tight
focus and energy of Black Panther.
This sequel is more scattered, a vast
expansion with a hole at its center."
This is a common theme among critics, as many
suggest it doesn't stack up to its predecessor.
To be fair, "Black Panther" is often hailed as
one of the best superhero movies of all time,
so it's not an insult to say
its sequel doesn't match it.
Robbie Collin of The Daily Telegraph
held nothing back, saying the film is
"A near-three-hour endurance run of gloomy
photography and turgidly staged, emotionally empty
two-way conversations, all seemingly designed
to sap cast and viewers' combined will to live."
Matt Singer of Screen Crush
calls the movie, quote,
"A messy sprawl of an ensemble piece"
and says in his review that watching
the original before seeing the sequel is
a bad move because it pales in comparison.
"Is this your king?"
Rolling Stone's K. Austin Collins offered
a balanced critique in his review, writing,
"The movie isn't always on such sure
footing. But that's almost appropriate:
a messier movie trying to reckon
with a messier range of feelings."
"When you left without saying a word, it hurt."
Additionally, some critics mentioned the movie is
just a little bit too long, like Owen Gleiberman
of Variety suggesting that 20 minutes could
have been shaved off of its 161-minute runtime.
Overall, "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever" appears
to be a great addition to the ever-expanding MCU.
Where it falls in the ranks is entirely up to
you, but if these reviews are any indication,
it's definitely in the top half.
Brian Truitt of USA Today wrote,
"Director Ryan Coogler delivers a
powerful follow-up to the phenomenal
2018 Black Panther that's funny, clever and
heartbreaking, impressive in its world-building,
honest in its view of world politics and
naturally packed with huge action sequences."
It definitely seems like it'll help
those suffering from Marvel fatigue
after the less-than-stellar Phase 4 films like
"Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness,"
"Eternals," and "Black Widow."
Ross Bonamine of Collider added,
"Wakanda Forever isn't perfect, but its
ability to handle this tightrope walk
between exploration of loss and a larger
superhero film makes this one of the most
moving MCU entries so far, and one of the best
films to come out of Marvel's Phase Four."
According to critics, it sounds like Coogler
has delivered a slightly messy but compelling
sequel to the original film.
Now all that's left is to see
what the fans think when "Wakanda Forever"
officially premieres on November 11, 2022.